et ukrainienne semble poursuivre sa
progression dans le nord-est de
l'Ukraine elle consolide ses positions
et pourrait bientôt lancer une offensive
en direction de la partie du don-basse
qui se trouve toujours sous contrôle
russe les occupants sont très clairement
en train de paniquer à déclarer volody
mirzky lundi d'ailleurs les dirigeants
prorus des régions séparatistes de
denisques et de Louhans ont appelé à la
tenue rapide de référendum objectif le
rattachement de leur République
autoproclamé à la Russie et nous
retrouvons notre envoyé spécial à
dergatchi Gulliver crack bonjour
Gulliver Gulliver l'armée ukrainienne
dit donc avancer vers le don de masse et
la région de louansk
oui c'est surtout leur succès à billero
Rifka un village qui est dans la région
de Luans qui fait parler de lui
aujourd'hui parce que c'est la première
prise confirmée de l'armée ukrainienne
dans la région de Luans depuis la prise
de la totalité de cette région par les
forces russes au mois de juillet quand
ils ont finalement pris les situations
qu'elle est village autour biler et pas
loin de Louane ce que l'Institut pour
les études de la guerre à Washington
confirme disque il y a des photos
géolocalisables qui montrent clairement
que c'est l'armée ukrainienne qui a
établit des positions dans ce village là
ce qui fait que la Russie ne peut plus
dire qu'elle contrôle ne contrôle plus
qu'une seule région de l'Ukraine si vous
voulez entièrement ce serait la Crimée
elle ne contrôle plus la totalité de la
région de luansk et elle n'a jamais
contrôlé la totalité de la région de
Donetsk où les forces ukrainiennes
avancent aussi dans la dans le nord de
cette région il tente de prendre avril
de Liman mais sans succès pour le moment
mais leurs estimations sont que ils
espèrent en tout cas avoir la
possibilité de le prendre sous une
semaine 10 jours c'est leur but en tout
cas bonjour Gulliver vous êtes à terget
c'est juste au nord de quartier quelle
est la situation là où vous vous trouvez
je pense que vous voyez derrière moi la
destruction ça c'est le résultat des
combats qu'il y a eu au printemps
pendant que les Russes essayaient encore
de prendre vraiment d'assaut la ville de
harkis la seconde ville du crâne il y a
beaucoup de destruction dans cette
bourgade et j'ai parlé tout à l'heure à
des gens qui font la queue devant le
poste de police pour essayer de demander
de la compensation financière pour la
reconstruction de leur maison la police
comme les gens qui étaient dans la queue
m'ont confirmé que ce serait quelque
chose qui prendrait vraiment beaucoup de
temps et qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui étaient intéressés pour remplir ces
formulaires ils savent que le processus
sera très long mais la femme à qui j'ai
parlé me disait que sa maison était
complètement détruite et vraiment elle
ne pouvait que continuer à espérer que
un jour au moins elle recevrait de
l'argent pour la reconstruire Gulliver